a
[Música]
en argentina como en todo el mundo con
las cuarentenas estrictas se potenció el
consumo de cursos a través de internet
cursos de cocina cursos de gimnasia
formación en baile en teatro de hecho
aquí en la ciudad de buenos aires- un
sector profundamente porteño que es el
del tango muy desde el inicio empezó a
volcarse a internet para dar cursos y
formaciones porque todos sus espacios
presenciales se vieron cerrado el tango
es un baile de mucho contacto que por
supuesto también a larrea mucho riesgo
entonces se volcaron a internet para dar
clases y para seguir en contacto con
alumnos con bailarines que están en
formación pero también descubrieron los
límites de la formación a través de
internet por un lado no traen los mismos
ingresos para quienes se dedican a esto
pero también hay un límite en cuanto se
puede enseñar a través de la pantalla y
cine el contacto entre el profesor la
profesora y sus alumnos y por eso es un
sector como muchos otros que está
desesperadamente esperando el momento
en poder volver a abrir y en poder
volver a dar sus clases de forma
presencial
[Música]
en perú la pandemia del cob y 19 obligó
a universidades institutos y diversas
entidades relacionadas a la educación al
llevar su metodología de enseñanza a un
entorno virtual la posibilidad de este
aprendizaje en internet son inagotables
existen clases virtuales en plataformas
un google mit ya sea en algunas redes
sociales en este país navegando en la
web se pueden encontrar cursos para
todos los gustos y los más importantes
para todos los bolsillos
los principales búsquedas son idiomas
cocinas música marketing cine teatro
coaching yoga y hasta algunas
disciplinas deportivas el boom de los
cursos virtuales generó el interés de
dos empresas extranjeras dedicadas a
tecnología que capacitarán a mil
docentes peruanos en aprendizaje digital
quizás la educación virtual no viene al
100% la tradicional enseñanza presencial
pero diversos especialistas sostienen
que si no fuera por la pandemia del cobi
19 tal vez no se hubiese ha revalorizado
el elemento virtual donde la innovación
tecnológica cumple un papel importante y
como señalan los expertos los cursos
virtuales llegaron para quedarse y todo
lo que los peruanos siempre quisieron
estudiar lo encuentran en lo que tarda
en hacer un clic en el computador
[Música]
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19 ha
habido una explosión de cursos en línea
que ofrecen universidades e institutos
privados y el propio gobierno para
ayudar a niños y adultos en el proceso
de enseñanza-aprendizaje
por ejemplo la open university que es
líder mundial en educación a distancia
ha registrado un incremento en sus
visitas diarias tan solo en la última
semana de 40.000 a 60.000 en todos los
cursos gratuitos en línea además el
gobierno lanzó una plataforma digital en
plena pandemia el pasado mes de abril
para que todos aquellos adultos puedan
mejorar sus habilidades numéricas y
digitales sin embargo los expertos
aseguran que se ha hecho más grande la
brecha digital entre las personas que
tienen acceso a una computadora e
internet y aquellas personas que se han
quedado rezagadas
[Música]